a damn phone away I will not I got the
names right this time oh good for you
SF's best sisters forever I wish I never
got to meet her but I did get to meet
Janelle Monae which is like a nice
second pretend I don't know who Janelle
Monae okay she's like the best singer
and she's a wonderful role model for all
young people and she's just lovely cool
look up the music video anyway she is
great and I was awesome to meet her so
that was it I went to Philly and I got
back yesterday at 10:00 p.m. and we
haven't recorded so let's record right
now and let's see where we're at so I
remember when we last spoke there was a
couple things that happened I got this
bug but when an object yeah and I got a
key I think it was the gold key and then
it you use the gold key to get this but
yeah I got the gold key and then I got a
silver key out of it right I think so
something like something like that and
now and then we were talking about
giving the hemostatic to that guy
Rodrigo yeah in the prison and we talked
about doing that so I think we should do
that this time
yeah and I just told you before someone
in the comments mentioned that I think
you could just combine the arrows with
the bow gun and it will not take up two
spaces let's find out oh they actually
spelled out combine here yeah but we
that's not how we roll here oh thank you
for the tip I got actually while you're
doing I'm gonna look the hood that was
good that was awesome okay I'm gonna
start the process yeah so right now
you're going back to the prison do you
remember how to get there nope you gotta
go past that cabin
oh also there's all those guys with the
arms the bandages the Bandersnatch is
and then I think there was other stuff
going on too like didn't we have the
option of like going into one of those
doors and then also doing the hemostatic
cuz I can't I don't know what you're
talking about I thought we had a heads
up if you are looking
I uh don't know yet but if you're look
at the timestamp and it's like 45
minutes supposed to an hour it's a
Friday evening and we're we're not
trying to rush anything but we also it's
a lot of people never know yeah cuz well
if we were recorded on a different day
would be fine but it's Friday evening
and I don't want to keep the staff here
yeah
that's rude our buddy gag its Frizzle
Friday are integral to the making sure
the site doesn't collapse dude - works
so hard already and I don't wanna keep
my hair crazy there ain't no man that
works on a Saturday more than my friend
gash or a Friday night and his only
fault is that he's a sharks fan the
Warriors game is on people got annoyed
that I said resin evil 3 isn't good
anymore well no I'm correct you guys are
all wrong so it's I just don't think it
aged well I think that's a fair women I
think it's a fair thing to say okay do
you remember if I go right or left here
that's my first query I think that I
think you're going the right way right
now mm-hmm
how sure are you oh no no sorry other
way that's to the sub I thought you had
gone to the left so actually there's a
comment here from Nathan Shepard thank
you very much and he said back to the
private residence with you guys in the
queen ant yeah we'll do that a second
statistics of the playthrough thus far
six deaths kills on Mary's part 75
Nathan Shepard 65 of which are zombies
five of which are zombie dogs as we know
this and five of which are banders
smooches chewed on by zom 33 damn zoms
health recoveries 11 sorry do I need
this ant for what we're doing
no but you're also not gonna fill up
your inventory so all right well I'm
going now when I go through here there's
bandar smooches so I need to know where
I'm going yeah I think you're just
heading you're not gonna you're not
gonna head into the courtyard with a
worm you're gonna keep coming right
towards me keep going yeah I keep coming
all the way toward the camera nice good
good Doge yeah oh [ __ ] you nice yes Oh
down there I got it I got it
dude that was such a good Juke okay here
we go
Jonathan whose line I'm so sorry if I
butchered that Jonathan haste line
mm-hmm I said some pro tips combine all
your arrows with your bow gun it can
hold them all then I'll free up a slot
so thank you okay Nate launcher works
the exact same way okay so holds like
endless grenades cool oh there might be
a dog where am I going down
no I think across the bridge if you go
down that's just Diggity Dog okay oh
yeah I remember that actually now I
totally forgot about this all right
oh and then all right well we learned
about that wasn't there like a dog or
something in here I thought there was
something yeah maybe he's just like a
alternate path maybe okay I just okay
okay cool this is where the dogs are
right or something oh you remember
I hear zombies do you hear them no I
[ __ ] hear them I [ __ ] heard that I
don't know okay I think it's that one uh
to my left no no no that's the cabin go
to the one to your right
I mean it'll reset them and then I can
figure it out
I can also kill them but I've I've heard
[ __ ] it looks like it I don't know where
ain't you yeah that's where you put out
the fire okay so yeah you go through the
graveyard right now you've got 210 O's
you can probably spare a few it sounds
like squishing your hand and spaghetti
get on the ground dead guy gonna let me
just just stab but let me get him stash
all right I think he's dead yep
body hello oh [ __ ] there's two of them
get on the grass it's really fun to say
we're just thinking a Bill Hader from
super bad I wonder if I can Juke this
guy it's not worth getting hurt over
I got idiot okay cool
where'd you get this beer the fresh
pills of bel-air I got it from twitch no
I mean like okay I got it where am i
from
beer near new glory craft brewery it
says one point of something random it's
not reassuring but I like this label
quite a lot oh cool another Oh gross
burden can buy new glory in Sacramento
very close by our way
capital have you seen Lady Bird yet I
just watched it on the plane yesterday
oh my god laughing it's pretty funny
right wing here it's pretty good when
she's like uh when he's like ah what are
you doing here I know you've lived in
the same rich is like God telling him
I'll kill your [ __ ] family she's
funny saoirse ronan i'm aesthetic
medicine how kind of you
okay thanks
[Music]
I wonder what he gives me let me help
you with that Thanks
I thought I told you here of myself
don't [ __ ] touch me oh wait what no
yes let me give you this more time you
might need it it's a toothpick
now go don't worry about me didn't he
die I have no clear oh that is big but
now you just have to sprint pass can you
pick up the lighter well you sleeping is
dead to me and get the letter him don't
think you can count on me in the future
now get out of here
oh I'm sure yeah it'll show up in the
nick of time at the eleventh hour can
use angry Oh Rodrigo's a dude that was
in charge of well not let me damn it
pick up my lighter
well now bats are new someone said
there's something in that stall I
thought what do you mean go into the
shower or sorry into the jail cell
uh-huh or shower one of them I think way
back on like Episode one someone was
like he forgot someone said we missed
something maybe it was in the stall Oh
like oh oh there's a [ __ ] plant in
there I'm so dumb oh well you didn't
really need it but now you do well no
you still know I'm fine but it's still
worth having mm-hmm so the lockpick oh
it's in it doesn't take up a slot it's
like in my now we go back to the private
residence okay I'm gonna need help with
that one too
that's all I know okay we'll figure it
out okay is it in the area that I'm in
or do I need to go to a new area I
honestly don't remember we'll figure it
out I think I think we are currently
figuring it out in we're now in the
situation to figure it out
good point I think we it's in the area
that you're already in it's that it's
that cabin where all the dogs were
around where they came out from the
vents underneath the cabin okay so yeah
just keep going straight so I just need
to find where is this guy you kill them
all just kidding
you almost got chewed on by us on yeah
well didn't he's got some lats
so there's some zombies in here I need
to find the area hmm okay is it in here
it's been completely nailed down oh wait
is there only two no no there's another
one over here
I [ __ ] just got hurt every set it to
go through the door right here yeah
that's the cabin I don't know if that's
the private residents are hurt from that
so this is a cabin I don't know if this
is the private residence but we could
check it out cuz you haven't been in
here a long time anyway it has been like
four hours has been a while since I've
been in this house
hello-o guess what you can open the door
the door aluminum case is now with a
lockpick and get some upgrades you there
in your save box you don't need them
right now yet but it's worth knowing
that looks like something I should be
able to open with a [ __ ] lockpick
sorry I'm a bit energetic today ooh all
right where am I going
uh here that's like the bathroom where
the zombie came through the window right
all right now it's just the bathroom
there was something it's a nice toilet
but also wow that's a really high up on
the wall tower to the toilet now is
there an upstairs
should I go upstairs sure I don't I
think just I don't know what's going on
here something tells me this isn't the
private residence this is not the
private remember the private residence
would be but there's another door here
yeah you try that
what's this okay I remember this
both this camera angles so mean yeah oh
that's where the dude came through the
window okay okay go this way
all right so this is a dead end this is
this is this is nothing town you go back
toward like the metal detector building
I remember that there I can still have
items in that metal detector you know
that yeah and we can we should be able
to make a shortcut so you can grab those
now I'm trying to remember how to get to
the middle of Tech you're building a map
is probably gonna be useful okay that
sounds important okay let's let's pull
up the map okay where did it come from
so that's this that's the typewriter
down there the purple diamonds which
means that is the prison cell to the
left of it I think no no that's a
different building this is where I came
from so now in the middle the sector is
I went through the top door and I went
up these stairs into this room yeah I
want to go to the left
are you uncocking or what I am
definitely on caution that's fine I'm
just making sure you were not like Rhett
know from one zombie I'm stronger than
that
oh yeah it was one zombie I'm a tough
girl is it there that's the one okay
just have fun
oh [ __ ] yes okay
okay this sounds familiar oh [ __ ]
alright come get some it's not worth
getting hurt here they're such
slow-moving arrows oops yeah you have
enough of those you still have like a
hundred ninety left yeah twitch for me
yeah Wow
he was fast he was faster than me yeah
Oh literally one more arrow okay so
annoying yeah what's in here there's the
guillotine
okay this door yeah what about it should
be able to open it with something I
don't have an in damn do you need the
army proof for that do you think oh I
don't know do you think they'd accept
bugs I don't even remember getting that
I don't remember getting anything that's
shaped like that that was the army proof
I think or the Eagle plate I don't have
an eagle place you go plate you put on
the submarine thing are you K
but it might just be the army proof
there's no any of them where would I get
sir is the Eagle play in the metal
detector oh [ __ ] yeah you check this out
Jesus same
I can hear them breathing please why how
come they're allowed to be in here but I
can't have my stuff I'll take anyway
yeah but I can hear them I need my gun
Z's to do this what do you mean I think
you might have reset it first oh you
need the extinguisher later as well but
that's later
so am i putting all my [ __ ] in here
again and going through it because I
[Music]
know back out so I'm pretty sure the
army proof or the Eagle plate either one
is what so I need to go to a save box
yeah but they're not the same shape the
Eagle plate was that shape wasn't it I
think the thing was like a hexagon maybe
it's the army proof that you need then I
don't know where that is
so this is the other side of the door
that goes yeah go toward the palace but
or just I say what's the closest save
box Palace right I mean that's not that
close but maybe
cuz that's a save but it's not save box
right I think so the palace might be
your best bet anyway cuz you can get the
duralumin case and unlock it with a
lockpick and have some stuff mm-hmm it's
not like that total it's not a loss of
time anything I mean it's definitely not
great fun stop
lady walk straight it's so hard to get
her to walk straight wait palace is the
other way oh no no you're right you go
back into that corner and then yeah well
gate true zom alley mm-hmm and then I
might need my map oh [ __ ] there's too
many of them
yeah it's like straight into the left
right no that's where you brought the
aesthetic yeah nope oh no no it's a big
door this way toward the camera yeah
it's the double one up top balls it's
got a dodge this dude Jukka me oh I
[ __ ] [ __ ] up Soviet sorry hug me so
dumb I like my swilled when I wanted to
suavo dad I was having such a good Jew
keys today too I was having some of my
best dukes of all time
yeah I want to know what that thing is
that I put in there oops
Oh rights boxes lady
all right and then I have to watch both
of these van der dudes and I really
can't get hurt too much because I think
I might die don't they do a lot of
damage should I heal up they do a damage
like I think they could kill me I didn't
mean to do that
I'm okay maybe I should go maybe I
should kill them I there's there's a
thing coming up that I would rather just
have as much ammo as possible for and
then after that we can make those kind
of decisions okay how far into the game
you think I am like a third yeah I'd say
something like that right so I'm getting
the aluminum case and I'm gonna lockpick
it is there anything else while I'm
around here that I think the army proof
in case okay why do I think you need the
Eagle plate for that I see if the army
proof is indeed the shape you need this
is a huge like [ __ ] around if it's not
what it is
but if it's not the thing it's a big
pain in the butt
you have the Eagle plane your inventory
or did you know I don't even know what
the Eagle plate is you use it a while
ago
scroll up no please circle around okay
so so I have you can combine that with
the other things for explosive area you
don't need that yet but get the
duralumon case yeah okay and use like
that for now okay with that
I understand combined yeah baby combined
[Music]
okay how about you check the case yeah
yeah a different one okay there's
another one with that so though that's
worth I think ten explosive arrows
that's good it's not what I'm interested
in right now okay like okay I need I
feel
the Eagle I'm gonna look okay I need the
Eagle II there's a panda six banders
smooch Jesus Christ my heart's gonna
blow up is I think that actually might
be the direction Oh God cuz there see
there's a door here yeah that goes up
the tower to where you overheard Alexia
and right alfrid
it's not worth dying over no no no I
know it you need to go up there
eventually but [ __ ] I just got hurt
don't caution that is where you need to
go for sure you sure sure
alright should I tell him or should I
run but you still know you cuz like
eventually you're gonna need the empty
fire extinguisher in the metal detector
which means which I don't have yet right
you need to create the shortcut in order
to avoid the metal detectors which means
you need the Eagle play but I'm trying
over no I don't need it to get the fire
extinguisher
oh no yeah you could just go there just
taking it yeah you should do that but I
was just there I thought that's what we
were doing
that's okay I'll play oh this is weird
no last time I played was co-op all
right so wait am I getting the fire
extinguisher yeah yeah let's do that
oh my god what a fine this is so okay
I'll tell I'll tell a six-story on the
way so it's not really like we're done
it yeah thank you
I just think you think of a story first
what was I gonna say
what do you going on this weekend just
pretty much started it's 5:30 on a
Friday
it's the Derby it's Derby Day I think
there's like a are you going to wills
thing tomorrow
I was double-booked I'm going to Wilson
um yeah uh Chris all Chris waters also
does like a derby oh yeah every year he
does it yeah I was there once it's very
fun but it's like two hours away
Berkeley I have to be honest with you I
get pretty lazy about like traveling
very far on my weekends I like to wake
up on slowly
I get like off Mary I like to eat
breakfast what are you doing yeah
getting out of San Francisco's annoying
it's not like taking the El train from
New York which is shut down now or soon
I think it's shut down now which sucks
Brooklyn residents yeah that's a Morgan
you tell it's late in the week thinking
sorry can I get the Eagle plate from
somewhere else I don't know what did you
use it for okay let's go chat wait in
the sub oh that way what's let's see if
it's there is it a sub thing
see that's oh that was a steering wheel
no it's not it's not the same I just
thought maybe it was like in here or
something maybe it is see it seems
stupid though that it would be the same
thing that I used in this sub but I
don't know I can't my memory sucks yeah
sure I just feel like we're going on
like a wild goose chase here
but I don't know any better this is
probably why a lot of people die playing
this game it's not it's not like cuz of
any fault it's just that if you don't
know where to go and you're walking in
random places you're gonna get like
punched a few times what you learn
something bad didn't you bad we're just
we need to be here i I do have a story
can I leave
yeah I don't want to be here no I do
have a story one time I was I was
recording this show yeah with my friend
Mary uh-huh
sorry amory uh-huh totally unrelated and
I realized that I was kind of I was late
in the week so I was kind of tired
and I let her like pretty much directly
away from where she needed to be yeah is
it yeah is it what's happening right no
no no this this what's happening now is
reminding me of what happened but this
is totally different
while we're time telling sorry can you
go back to where you were earlier out to
the palace to that gold lugar room with
the bandar snitch yeah see what's up
there you told me no no no no this is a
different story that happened a few
years ago I was younger and dumber
how dumb were you how did you get Dumber
alcohol time age it was prior do you
want me to keep going
drugs no I was kidding neither should
you
what a dumb steering wheel it doesn't do
anything of value I know you could just
swim over there if you wanted to what's
the water is infected do I need to kill
this Bandar snitch no I need to run from
him and go in that door yeah have you
seen a usual suspects um or true
detective yes you've senior detective
seen true detective season those shows
are really good cuz they bring up the
question of like an unreliable narrator
and unreliable guide I think that's what
I'm running to this series someone that
you can't really know if he trusts or
not that's exactly what I'm going for
that's why I'm [ __ ] up like this um
yeah go through the blue grid or go back
up to thank God see what's up there
this guy's gonna punch me again I just
know it oh the Bandersnatch that's
actually what it's called
Oh God dodge left go left go left left
go up he's still got me [ __ ] off so I
hope everyone's weekend is going well
this is the closest I think we've to an
episode publishing that we've recorded
so this tomorrow people are will be
watching us yeah okay so getting close
to it but I hope ever having a nice
Saturday well know if you're across the
pond it's it seems Sunday technically I
don't like this you've been here before
I know but I don't like it now yeah I'll
be fine trust me yeah private residents
back here you know I should have
listened to that original me comment
that's was it me I don't think so no
there's something wrong with that angel
yes ribs are showing oh my god upstairs
all right so take a quick right mm-hmm
stop it stop it stop it stop it there we
go take a quick right and go up the
stairs yeah [ __ ] we're all right just
take off I don't know where I am
there's like literally a hard left to
Jill's left is a sorry Claire's left is
us there's whoa no not at all actually
so I need to go right and go up these
stairs it looks like it oh my god oh
[ __ ] guys
don't you're like an Avenger don't die
on me oh no just just chew Kim Phuc yeah
nice Oh planned it all along those
stupid things are everywhere this sounds
not good why is this place bad am I
going left or up these stairs I need you
to be with me on this let's check out
left while you're down here I know oh no
oh I wonder what's do that door what am
i caution you're fine you'll know if
you're on danger just go through that
door go around all right take a left
Mary and pick up yeah there you go
you're fine
yes nice this padded door I can't
believe I lost a lighter yeah yeah oh
that looks what does that better
smooches are everywhere oh my god
okay I don't here's my strategy don't
let him hit you but check the rest of
the room yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
okay
banished smooch eliminated that score
one for us in like 12 for them Jesus you
were in here before but I forgot what
happened is this where we like caught
the kids making out or something
something that happened to you that
looks like a does it not look like the
thing we want uh oh never I see it from
different angles no you're going
upstairs what was in here though is
where the army proof was I don't know
just kill this stupid smooch for nothing
it was satisfying it's a morale boost
for me at least oh my god
up the stairs okay oh is this is this
when you revert back to checking the map
compulsively I shot up [ __ ] bats that
resident before you did that yes and
every time you get mad at me because I
like wanted to look at stuff well I was
kidding but you're you're really I mean
take a right and then a left
that's if I died a bats and then be
really mad if I think what the most
embarrassing death was on Resident Evil
here's your coat nice weather it was
during coop or just you playing oh this
is interesting
I'm liking this so he's dead you're good
nice thank God for the bogan right no no
reloads and thank God for Jonathan who
told as you can combine that I forgot
about that
on the ground
jerk okay so there was like something
here [ __ ] how many Psalms are in here
yeah he's probably over there that's
bold Mary
[Music]
I mean arrows you have left not a lot am
I in trouble
no all right a common Saudis the door
where they were talking in the bedroom I
don't know I think so
please don't have a bandar thing I can't
afford it oh look at oh yeah I think I
got a bug for that what bet your ass
there is yeah I [ __ ] know
[Music]
yes what that's go is it just my
position go
I don't know yeah go hmm that seems
really weird
you're definitely supposed to put the
ant in the ant shaped opening yeah yeah
maybe I mean it's obviously what it's
for it's and it shows it to me okay so I
know there's another ant but check out
check the rest of this room there's a
second and yes but check the rest of
this room that's statue did something
right this one yeah yeah yeah I keep
checking around or go down the other
side of the hallway actually alright
remember there was another there's more
than this room yeah just give me a bug
shaped indent and be like
and then no no sorry
yeah back this way keep going toward the
camera once it changes
yeah down there
creep
[ __ ] is wrong with that wall why I think
that happens when you have an entered
room I think oh no what is happening oh
you have the lockpick now I don't know
[Music]
sorry that was me oh my god like I was
cranking the volume okay here we go
this sounds familiar this song well
[Music]
something is written on the back of the
lid
Red Queen blue King return the path
opens you have the Red Queen and right
so I need another ant stop the music box
yes oh okay okay okay wait where was
that I don't know a bed on the bed yeah
don't put that there yet why not cuz you
go get the key just to make sure you oh
in case like [ __ ] goes down where was
that it was on the bed I think you could
just put should I not do that uh [ __ ] I
don't know okay I'm gonna put the Spidey
on there now
I just feel sure I mean to do that okay
that's it yeah I mean at least it's out
I think you need both of them eventually
anyway all right going in Oh Lord a hole
in the ceiling has been sealed oh I
can't okay well you got the silver key
well that's big that's the next piece of
the puzzle I can't believe there's no
health in here MA a great look for me is
that Alright
so silver key mm-hmm okay so what am I
doing with us the silver door was
somewhere in the palace so you're not
far you just have to go past those
bandages to get back to the palace just
don't die because that would really suck
I hate
how's my own I'm not great just you're
coming back here you could go all out on
one of the banners smash up top just to
wreck him with arrows but I don't think
that staggers him enough to prevent him
from hitting you know I don't think it
does either we could try just [ __ ]
alright so BAM that from top are they in
the top no no not in the the only if the
worst is the this is the bats right yes
and then when you leave it's got it yeah
it's like totally not worth dying like
I've been through it no goddamn bats
yeah as long as you get to the stairs
okay so I'm leaving that door with that
and then they're out here there's one
right here and yeah what do I do where
my going I don't know just kill him
no dodgem nice there you go
you gonna jump down don't panic he's
gonna follow you just stick close to
this dude yeah dodging nice guys you
coming door we're upstairs that's job
[ __ ] Alan I ever seen
yikes so could you use the silver key to
get rid of it once you get back to the
palace should be around there bottom
second floor I think and then save it
yeah more done I feel like your spirits
are low and you should be alright my
baby heart though like I don't wanna die
this close there's one in here oh my god
I forgot I thought it was believed I
used to take a left and then take a
right there's gonna be on the far wall
mm-hmm
hey sweet Jimmy I see with the silver
key opens you may yeah it's definitely
in the palace okay so it's in here no
not in this room but in the palace okay
let's do that hopefully won't kill me
the key
No whatever in that room oh no you don't
have to go in the room yeah you can
check it out if you want it's not I
don't think it's going to well I'm like
in this is it isn't it like right here
so yeah like you might as well see it
right log has been released hopefully
that's oh it's a sad sign even the last
time you're using something that's the
big deal the next episode is gonna be
interesting
you need some stuff here it's a casino
what it's a more
some playing cards mm-hmm look like a
playing cards can i gamble I love when
they let you gamble in games which is
all the games thank my lucky but I
really needed that you know what I
haven't seen a lot of in this game red
herbs that you combine it's always green
it's weird right
chai plays piano okay it sounds
important though oh and joint green herb
yeah I can use that oh cool I'm gonna
before hello is that it that's what I
came in here for for now you got the
handgun rounds right yeah the other
silver key door should be downstairs
let's do it um no no no no you should
but be ready to kill some stuff are you
serious yeah yeah am I gonna die it's
not worth dying over have two herbs
we've done an entire episode we have two
are beautifully fine it's okay should I
use the bow gun or my gun gun I'll use
my gun gun yeah yeah you go locked and
loaded baby wait I forgot to equip it no
I didn't I'm good
I got it yeah is it I forget where
that's the bathroom I go in there a lot
yeah you do
oh no this might be the bathroom
if this is the bathroom really mad that
might be the silver there you go yeah
wow you should be able to discard that
okay yes yes I'm so freaked out worse
comes to worse just turn around and go
back to it is it Bandersnatch yep
no there's multiple yeah now you're fine
yeah just [ __ ] waste them we're too
far for him no he's not check your
health quick should I combine the green
yeah and start shooting really fast that
is as fast as you shoot man oh no you
[ __ ] oh god I [ __ ] got hurt pretty
bad
alright no you're fine I'm one yellow
okay they're dead that's job there's
some stuff in here and then we could
probably call in episodes oh no remember
him
rest equal to the only dude that
survives us outside of um he was a
member of one of the extraction teams he
was the only dude outside of Leon and
Claire that serve Leon and Jill good ol
hunk no Leon Claire that survives
I arrived successfully from the umbrella
transport base stream care was taken
it's in the freezer we are normally
assigned to special missions why are we
ordered to transport a frozen capsule at
this time without knowledge of the
contents it's harmful
I want more info will gear up for the
next mission at 11 p.m. me hunk sweet
scan the restroom then you can save it
you got it dude that's a tea set
that's bullies oh my God if I didn't
take both of those herbs I think I would
have died that's so scary like how close
that was there's weight something under
that dudes body looks like a boardroom
oh oh there she is
sweet and I can go saving now we know
what we're doing next time cool on your
way to Antarctica fish you got some
stuff to do for sure
next episode woof that was scary mmm
but that's Resident Evil not saving for
a while and being terrified okay so here
you know that by now and then upstairs
and then CB and I don't think there's
any dudes in here so I think I've been I
think I'm getting away with this
scot-free mm-hmm
unless they add more Benedict
Cumberbatch's down here I would not put
pass them and a dick bandar smooches a
dick Bandersnatch Benedict cumbers
smooch is such a great Doctor Strange
Nicole yay so I have this thingy just
keep that in there so you remember okay
I feel like I'm running out of ink
ribbons no you'll you'll find more okay
five you're fine
pretty good it's a bad thought the max
or just keep going I don't know all
right good job sweet all right that was
good stuff that was scary
but we made it okay well thank you for
watching as usual our buddy
on a Saturday I hope you have a good
rest of the weekend yeah I hope you guys
enjoy your weekend thanks coming on
Friday
you are welcome thanks for doing this on
a Friday when I was gone the whole week
next week I am here the whole week so we
can record a DubLi episode I don't wanna
miss that okay well I guess we're kind
of locked into it now anything for the
people watching see you guys next time
bye bye bye Oh buddy
I once a guy have to pee so bad you
always have to be it's just how my
bladder